Today's topic
we have, uh, yet another Karen that decided to cry on camera.
So let's pop it in Mika Stauffer. So this.
Is by far the hardest video James and I have ever. Yeah.
Publicly had to make little.
Context. Mika was adopting a young boy from, I believe it's China.
The boy did have a, no say correctly. What? From where China. Thank you.
And, uh, the boy did have a preexisting condition. Uh, what was it?
Are you aware? Autism. Okay.
And essentially she made a whole bunch of videos talking about the process
of adopting him.
A whole bunch of people started following her. She need a lot of money.
She went through the process and then three years, uh,
went by and eventually people come to find out that she had given up the child
to somebody else because he was too difficult to handle. That's the gist of it.
So let's watch her video as she apologizes to a lot of the outrage that's
happened since the, um, letting go of the child.
But before I get into the video, I did,
I just wanna say thank you to how amazing our
viewers have been.
We have some viewers who have been just like so incredibly kind and respectful
of our son's privacy. I just wanna say,
thank you like that really got me through some really hard times.
The viewers have been respectful of your son's pride yet.
You're the one that puts your son's privacy out there.
What do that again? What? Go ahead.
Look for it. Search for it. Search for the logic. Can you find it? Yes.
No, keep searching. Huh? Ooh. Air shot. Lee. Where is Charlie?
Where is he? What the, what did you just say? Uhhuh. Hey, Hey. Hey.
Hey, she's the victim? Let's listen to her. Yes. I'm sorry. I'm.
Sorry. It's and I just wanna say,
thanks like you have no idea what that means to
me and this, some of the special messages that you've sent, like just.
My mouth, my mouth I'm I'm dancing because you know what?
Mike here comes the while work. Thank you for.
The.
I can't say enough how hard Micah has tried throughout this entire journey
and the amount effort she's put into this and helping Huxley as much
as she can. So, I mean,
you guys have been part of this adoption journey even before.
War works. Part two, let's go.
I definitely approve of everything being all white in this image,
cuz it definitely gives an image of like sincerity, sureness,
really trying to create reconciliation piece. Don't forget the beige backdrop.
Okay. But let's listen. I think,
I think we're being too judgemental because of our own biases.
We Haven's give a chance. We haven't said. We said a lot. Okay.
Look at your face. Now continue dancing.
You know, we, we picked up Huxley throughout the whole process and you know,
with international adoption,
sometimes there's unknowns and things that are not transparent on files and
things like that. And once Huxley came home,
there was a lot more special needs that we weren't aware of.
And that we were not.
Told, okay, I have to stop at because he lied. All right,
let's just start there. You got Ruthie. And, and not against.
This physician, you know, she's just listening to what other doctors,
other neurosurgeons and um, neurodevelopment specialists are telling her,
but um, her prognosis and everything for our son just went drastic.
She kind of almost discouraged us from adopting him like saying that this is
going to be severe. This is going to be a lot, you know,
we don't know what unknown elements could be. It was hard.
It was hard to hear somebody say that if anything,
my child is not returnable though.
When I heard all of the things that that doctor was telling us,
it kind of went in one ear and out the other,
no matter what state he came to us, that we would love him.
And that's one thing that I about this process.
My child is not.
You got Ruthie.
Ooh, I,
now I got this clip from spill se all right, now she did a great job on,
on her video on this. So you can go check her out. Spill fish. Yes. Ooh.
I couldn't find the original vlog cuz unfortunately she took 'em down.
She took 'em down. So people wouldn't be able to catch all the receipts,
but some people did. So thank you for that.
Really hard hearing from the medical professionals,
a lot of their feedback and things that have been
really upsetting for us because
this is not what we've ever wanted to hear.
We've never wanted to be in this position.
I don't think anybody's saying that you guys wanted to be in this position,
but you guys were negligent.
And the thing about becoming a parent and choosing to adopt a child from a place
like that into your home, into your circumstances, knowing what he has at, uh,
I don't believe that you wanted this outcome,
but you were so incredibly negligent that it still reflects poorly on your
character. The thing that happened you're I just wanna finish this. Yeah,
go ahead. Try you. You, you, you drink and drive.
You don't intend to kill 10 people when you do it.
But it's changed the fact that you're very negligent in that same token.
This is that level of negligence. Don't adopt children.
Don't bring them in and you kept them for three years.
There are other adoptions that happen where a child is brought in.
It doesn't work,
but they tell you to make sure that you return that child as soon as possible as
to not scar them, you kept this child for three years.
And to add to the fact that you profit off of them financially,
it looks exponentially worse.
It looks exponentially worse on you.
Go ahead. The thing that happened is that sometimes you have a, you, you have a,
a want a goal. Mm-hmm <affirmative> right as wanting a child,
you want a child and wanting that child so much. Mm
surpasses you being able to see you,
you lose any kind of sense of logic and you don't,
you don't see all the other outcomes.
And even if people tell you, no, you really want that child.
I've seen some people wanted to get married. They didn't want,
they didn't want a relationship. They wanted a wedding SIM ceremony.
I understand. And them wanting that, that goal,
that image that they had as a little girl, as a little,
you are having that surpassed everything that no, don't, don't go into that.
You're going too quick. This is not the right thing.
It didn't matter because their goal, their goal was bigger than reason.
I, I E I will get this no matter what.
And that's what happened. You wanted this child no matter what.
And we've.
Been trying to get him, get his needs met and help him out as much as possible.
It's really aren't his Zach, Right?
We truly love him.
There's not an ounce of our body that doesn't love her sleep with fall over me.
There wasn't a, a minute that I didn't try our hardest.
And that's why like on Instagram and stuff, I've tried to like,
let you know as little as I could,
but I couldn't tell you anymore because I didn't wanna mess anything up
with what's going on legally. And if I said something,
was I gonna mess up things for his future?
I just, I don't know something about white women and crying.
They always try to make them selves off to be the victim of the situation. I,
I just can't stand it.
I really just can't you traumatized a child and you want me to believe you're
the victim? No, you were the negligent one. You could be remorseful,
but you getting on here to cry and be like, I just,
I was trying to be a good person. I was trying to be,
you don't need to hear to that.
You up explain how you were negligent except the responsibility and the
criticisms that you're receiving and take that.
And it's not people it's not because people are not criticizing you.
That are being honor as being, there's so much people that, you know,
there's some people there's so much people that have been, so this is like,
they're so respectful. And so, you know, so nice known.
They're just not holding you accountable.
<Affirmative>.
And it's just been a really hard place to be in. Like,
because you're grieving you. I wanna share with you guys,
like I know deep down inside that I don't have to say anything. Like, I'm not,
I don't have to say this. I don't have to, but I want to, like,
I want to tell you guys have been there for us so much. And I wanna,
I wanna fill you in on what's going on and what hard, like,
do I feel like a failure as a mom? Like 500%.
So when you get like insidious hurtful comments,
it just like really makes it hurt worse. It's not about me at all,
but it's just like this. Oh, oh.
Set up. Shut your mouth. It is set up.
You set up your mouth. VIN.
It's it's not about me. It's not about me,
but you make old V about you or shut up your mouth.
So AB okay.
Okay. <laugh> okay. Not about me. So you, you,
you go do I feel like a failure as a mother,
5000% and it hurts exponentially more.
When you guys write insidious comments about me, it hurts,
but this is not about me. So then why are you?
I instantly talking about how both, how bad both of you feel math?
BKU math.
It's like saying me, me, me, me, me, me, but it's not about me.
That's exactly what happened. That's exactly what happened though.
That's exactly what that's exactly what you did. Me, me, me, me, me, me, me. I,
I feel that I feel, we, me, we, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, we, me, we,
me. It's not about me. All right.
If you don't the outta here,
play the thing. I'm not no laughing. I'm just gonna leave out there.
The last couple months have been like the hardest thing I could have ever
imagined going to choosing to do,
because ultimately after pouring our guts in
our heart, into this little boy.
The reason why we can't go a detail of what actually
transpired is because we're truly going to protect Huxley's privacy and not let
people know.
Okay? Okay. I, I, I, I was gonna wait till the end,
but you've repeated this 0.5 times. I can't Joe, get in. I can't get 'em.
I have a big problem with YouTubers putting their kids online. I'm sorry,
but you turning your children into content and you monetizing.
It is a big issue to me and it affects your parenting.
It affects your relationship to, with them and it affects their psyche.
So don't sit here and say, I was trying to respect their privacy.
When you've made hundreds of thousands of dollars on a child that you abandoned,
you can miss me with that denim. That is absolute nons sense.
How many more YouTubers do we have to see?
Stop putting their kids up on YouTube?
Because they recognize how toxic it is for you to sit there and be like,
oh my God, I'm trying to respect their privacy. No,
now that you can't monetize it,
you're trying to make yourself look like a good person.
But don't say that you're trying to respect their privacy. That's ridiculous.
That's nonsense. Go on with that ugly jacket. Tell 'em.
You're I can't with this. This is too much there.
There's something really perverse about that. Absolutely. You are.
You are trading your child's future and their wellbeing for money and,
and we're watching it happen in real time for other people's entertainment.
It's disgusting. And with adults, I wouldn't even do with my family members.
I keep my family members off. But with adults, at least they can consent. Yep.
With children, they can't. Hmm. And now that you don't have it no more.
You're just gonna ring back. And right now I wanna protect them.
But all these videos that you did, you wanna protect them. Girl, if you don't
get the whole, the you and your hubby
gotta hear.
What happened to what, everything that went on to make us make this decision,
this decision,
or to even come to medical professionals with the need to get more, help,
anything that happened in the home, that hard for hooks.
That's not fair for me to put out there publicly. That's his.
Privacy. So we're not. No, no, no,
no. Now that it's hard and everything and stuff. It's all about PR. No.
He can't say, right? No. Boo boo bear.
I really wanna say, uh, we know they know no,
which no, which feels kind of good though, which is pretty nice,
which is pretty nice. Which is a great, I'm gonna say this. God's got it. Ice.
Woo. I got it. No witch. We don't believe you. Now that it's done. No.
Let me ask you guys this all right. With a sincerity.
Do you guys believe what she's saying? Sincere.
And if you do I ask you one question, had this been her biological child,
do you think she would've tried to abandoned it?
Just because she had the option. She could, it was not truly hers.
And she knew that at the end of the day, that's why she returned it.
So she didn't truly love the kid. As a mother would love the kid.
It is what it is a shy go in peace.
If you guys look at deadbeat fathers like trash, that's trash, right there.
There you go. You left your key O great analogy. Let's see. So.
We're not gonna talk about that. That's not, that's not appropriate.
Like that's, and that'll never be appropriate.
I didn't adopt a little boy to share these
things publicly every now and then you may have gotten like a teeny,
like struggle or like a hardship when I was trying to be like really raw and
real, but we haven't intentionally like day one,
intentionally 99,
90 5% of the struggles we have never publicly aired at ever,
ever with pure intent of respecting his privacy.
Not to give you a fake facade or to be lack of transparency,
but to respect our son's privacy.
And this is all that we're okay with sharing.
The reason we haven't updated you sooner is because the medical professionals,
the agency is multiple.
People have been allowed for Huxley to spend time with some different people,
to see,
and to make the perfect match and fit for his now new
forever family from the updates we've gotten from the agency and.
Forever family sounds funny when you were supposed to be that guess forever's
not forever. If it's an option, is it forever is like
not forever till death do his part, but than again, if something happens,
I'm gonna opt out, okay.
Through the adoption agency, like they were able to place him.
And what they felt was literally the perfect match. When we met,
like Jimmy said earlier, when we got hugs,
we didn't know a lot of these unknowns and when.
Age stop lying, all right, I'm done, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. It's like, yeah. Her new mother has as, as all like, you know,
medical. What about all these mothers and fathers that have artists,
autistic children, and they don't have the,
the medical capacities and they still go through it. All right.
I'm gonna wrap it up on this point.
I know a lot of white people who got this white savior complex.
That's what this looks like to me. Can't say for Shep, just my hunch.
I know too many white women who left to go to Africa with zero skill sets
pertaining like building a school,
pay a whole bunch of money and then take a whole bunch of social media pictures
for social currency to get their feeling of superiority and leave this what that
look like to me, because the moment actually got hard.
Turns out you didn't really want to help turns out you weren't actually there
for the struggle. You were just there to make yourself feel good. Oh yeah.
Well, yeah. And once you didn't feel good, no more. You opt out. Yeah.
Because all those bricks that you guys laid up in Africa, they get taken down.
We just let you to come here for the money. That's it. That's all it was for.
So I want her to miss me with all this other nonsense. I find it so disgusting.
Whenever people were third world countries and run these little gambits.
All right. There's all kinds of problems with the adoption process.
And that's a whole different story. But when it comes to this stuff,
it reeks of that issue of like,
I'm gonna go to a third world country and just prove how much of a good person I
am just to reinforce my own ideas of myself, you know,
because I just grew up in like such like a sheltered life.
And I just want to make sure that I can convince myself that like I'm a good
person. Yeah. Yes. What do you think about her white tears? Man, listen,
white women in their tears. I just, I don't know what it is.
I think I'm inoculate. I can start dancing every time I hear that. I'm like, oh,
let me just go on my little. Mm. I just can't buy some of them. Just do.
You can just tell what it's for. Yep.
And I've just seen too many of them use it and weaponize it as a means of self
defense. And I'm just like, no, no, you're not gonna manipulate me anymore.
You're not gonna gain my sympathy. I'm not, I can encourage this.
So that hopefully the next generation of girls who grew up,
don't look at this behavior and be like, when I'm in trouble,
I'm gonna just cry to get out of it. Nah, nah, I'm not with that.
So that's all I have to say.
Okay. Michael Jackson with a <laugh> boy,
if you don't get the outta here. Oh,
<laugh> what the did you get this?
I had hit my closet for a minute. When it's time to get wild, I get wild.
This is really, uh, I never really took a look at it. What that, what is it?
What you gonna say? It's ugly as how's it ugly?
It's ugly as nah. This fired B QV. Yo, hold on. Hold. Yo. Get out the way.
What do you mean? How do you mean you don't think this fired by?
It's ugly as fire. Yo, I got shoulder pants back in the seventies.
You know where I got this? My mom. Of course you did.
Apparently my mom got some skills.
Y cause you know how mom used to boogie down when it was hot on hot. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. You gonna turn off the air conditioner. I don't have,
I don't have any shoulder pads on none of my. You know why?
Cause you got big shoulders. Yeah. He's just mad.
Or maybe cause you mom, ain't got some nice clothes.
Oh what'd you say about your mama? What? Yeah.
<laugh> that you wearing? Your mom was clothes. Yeah. I don't mind.
My mom got some good, good.
Re re reuse passed down from generation to generation. That's right.
That's right. Still in the closet. No, no, no, no. I pulled it out. What's up?
Oh, once I pull out the once I pull this out of my closet, the girls are like,
pull something else out for me. Won't you?
Everybody knows. Yeah. Yeah. Boy, if you don't get another of the shirt,
let nice. Anyways. Let's go. Let's go. Let's start. Let's start. Let's start.
Let's start. Let's start. Listen.
Let me wear out what I wear you don't you listen.
You wear bathrooms to do videos and my bathroom. Yeah, exactly.
So how about you? Don't shut the up my ad bathrooms. Try to talk to me about,
uh, I wanna wear bathrooms. Okay. Then wear them. I don't say nothing.
Cause they nice. Yeah. No you think they're nice. They're nice.
You think they're nice. They super nice. And you're allowed to wear them.
My bathrooms. People be like, yo, why is bridge wearing a bathroom in public?
Cuz my is exactly. It's all about just let people do what they want to do.
All right. Go ahead. Superstars. All right. Let's start today's topic. Yeah.
Those girls messing the other day.
Hating on your cause you had this red shirt with Sirracha and she's like, no,
no, no, no. Where I'm from. It's just unacceptable. Red is an artist. His pilot.
Please tell him to change. I was like, if you don't up the outta here.
Is that the same Jasmine? No, it's another one. Oh,
another one that wanted my Jasmine Jasmine's been leaving you alone. Yeah.
Cuz you told her to leave me alone. <laugh> leave.
<laugh> didn't you don't leave my alone. No. You know what I did?
I asked her basically why she was so cheesed with you.
I didn't understand like what was her, what was obsession?
There's there's no sense. Yeah. There was. That makes no sense. It was weird.
It was weird. It was super weird. And,
and especially cuz I talked to her and she was a decent person. So I was like,
why do you get outta the way? Yeah. You know, that's the weird thing.
When you speak to somebody who engages like negative comments,
but that you realize like, oh this is like not necessarily a bad person.
They just say foul things on the internet. Yeah.
Cause they just want and they just can. Yeah. And then I think,
I think after we spoke, she, she explained it to so what was it about her?
This broad. Well, she doesn't like you that's for sure. What's just fine. Yes.
But it's the reason she expressed it. I and I was, and I think,
I don't think she realizes it,
but I think a lot of people just do it cuz the internet and they feel a
disconnect from the people that they're talking about.
So they don't recognize with us.
There's not a real impact with when they say that stuff. Oh, for me,
I'm just curious as to, why would you say it? Yeah.
But because even I would never think of saying that to strangers,
but I do also admit this. I will admit this. Go ahead.
Sometimes when I'm replying to comments online,
I am a little bit more stern than I would be if I was faced somebody,
but I would never stoop to the level that they stupid. Yo, she went low, low.
I'm just like, yo, if you don't like me, that's fine. That is super fun. Yeah.
But Lil she went just out. She was out there. Yeah. Super out there.
But anyways,
and then it's one thing to hate someone
but paying to hate <laugh> that I that's a,
that's a new level to be fair though. She's just a big supporter of mine.
So she was giving me money. Okay. What was being petty at the same time. Okay.
But she gonna realize that I have the money's going to me dumb.
We'll cut that part up. Yeah. Don't I said what I said. All right. Let's
I can't put that word in.